I'm Evan G borin I am the faculty
director of the center prior art science
and technology it's great to see you all
here and I mean that both in the general
sense and in the specific sense of those
of you who came back to to hear the
following performance this is actually
the first half of the quote-unquote
audible panel that joins the other more
traditional panels but since it involves
music we just thought it would be really
nice to just have the audible panel be
music itself so we have two really
incredible creative musicians who are
going to be performing their work for
you later on at 6:15 my advisor will be
performing her collaboration with
Michael Harrison and bill Morrison
called just aims and loops but I want to
introduce grace Leslie to you now in
terms of the theme of this conference
being material we tried to think about
ways in which material in the musical
sense could be rethought of other than
in the oh let's let's bring out new
innovations in stuff being used to
generate music and really get back to
the fundamentals of the materials of
music oddly enough my introduction to
experimental music came when I was 13
years old and I had this incredible
music teacher in high school who taught
a class called materials of music and in
this class materials of music we learned
about everything other than material we
learned about these malleable objects
and shapes and formal designs that were
all completely abstract they all had to
do with things like melodies and the
form of music etc etc and one of the
things that she Betty Jacobson first
introduced me to when I had barely hit
adolescence was the work of Alvin Lucier
and so she kind of blew our minds by
playing I'm sitting in a room to a to a
bunch of 13-year old sitting in a room
and of course Alvin was our guest
musician two years ago at our first
symposium and he performed I am sitting
in a room and he also talked about his
piece music for solo performer which was
one of the earliest and most successful
and certainly groundbreaking pieces that
involved using brain waves to generate
music and so it seemed really natural
that for this brain waves being the most
latent material that I think could
possibly generate music to bring that up
to date 2017 by bringing somebody else
who's making music with brain waves and
that is Grace Leslie she's currently a
visiting scientist at the Media Lab
she's a composer and a researcher she
will be a Newcombe fellow at Dartmouth
next year and then she will take a
faculty position at Georgia Tech those
are her credentials for her daily
affirmation but I want to just say a
little bit more about what she's going
to be doing so this also relates to
Nicholas Negroponte whose comments both
his final comments first about the
natural and the artificial becoming one
because I'll get back to that but also
his brief comment about biotech as the
digital of the future because in
addition to Grace's research work and
her musical work she is very involved in
using music both in traditional forms
and in terms of music generated by brain
waves in therapeutic situations and
working toward wellness so that directly
relates to what Nicholas was telling us
but in terms of natural and artificial
what grace does is that she's going to
be generating the music that you hear
basically by three means one of them the
most traditional means of making music
which is taking a physical object and
causing it to vibrate the air around it
by blowing through it and that would be
her on her flute simultaneously she's
measuring her own brain activity and and
her brainwaves are in turn triggering
synthesized and sampled sounds that
she's also created so she's taking the
material of music being pushing air
pressure around the room in various ways
at its absolutely most molecular and
wave-like way and this is her piece
vessels
[Applause]